in Canada and the quality of the air
here in the East Coast
this blanket of the communities in the
east coast and uh
and the smoke this past few days
I just put out a more detailed statement
so for the press and for the people to
see but I spoke yesterday with prime
minister Trudeau
and I've decided to dictated a National
interagency Fire Center
response to Canada's request for
additional firefighters and the fire
suppression assets such as air tankers
we already have 600 American
firefighters on the ground and been
there for a while in Canada including
Hot Shots and the smoke jumper Crews and
it's very important that affected
communities listen to the guidance of
their state and local officials from
this point forward
to keep up to date on the air quality in
real time go to the app that we provide
it's called airnow.gov
and check on one another and by the way
what you'll get is something that looks
like this with a with a calibrated piece
that says when the air is clean and when
the air is dangerous and hazardous and
it dictates what to tell you the air
quality in your the neighborhood now
it's uh it's my honor my honor to
welcome prime minister sunac to the
White House
appreci we've uh we're probably tired of
meeting we met in March
and uh and San Diego to discuss August
and with prime minister of Australia in
April we were there for the 25th
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
in Belfast we met and discussed again
today the
the need to get the Stormont institution
Northern Ireland up and running last
month together with our G7 partners and
Hiroshima we drove progress in
everything from our shared support for
the brave people of Ukraine to the
common principles of engaging it with
China
today in Washington we have had an
important and positive discussions to
deepen our bilateral economic
relationship
and expand our cooperation to shape the
challenges and future for this remainder
of this century
it's a testament to the depth breath and
I would argue the intensity of our
cooperation and coordination which has
existed continues to mix between the
United Kingdom and the United States
there's no issue of global appoint of
importance none that where our nations
are not leading together and where we're
not sharing our common values to make
things better
and our conversations today
we continue to build on all that we've
achieved over these past months
we discussed how we can continue to
adapt and upgrade our partnership
to ensure our countries remain at The
Cutting Edge I'm going to rapidly
changing world
our economic partnership is enormous
strength and source of strength that
anchors everything that we do together
we want to harness that power to make
sure we're creating good jobs and
supporting working class families in
both our countries
and the growth is shared broadly and no
one gets left behind
So today we're releasing a new plan to
equip our economic partnership for the
21st century
it outlines how we can enhance our
cooperation to accelerate the clean
energy transition that must take place
and is taking place
lead the development of emerging
Technologies are going to shape so much
of our future
and protect Technologies critical to our
national security
and a key piece of that is working
together to strengthen our critical
mineral Supply chains and to make them
more resilient so we're not dependent in
any one country to meet our goals
when it came when it comes to technology
that will shape the future like
semiconductors Quantum Computing
artificial intelligence the UK and the
U.S are working together to make sure
they are developed safely and
responsibly and jointly
we're going to do more on joint research
and development to ensure the future
we're building remains a fundamentally
aligned with our value set in both our
countries and we're doing more to
prevent technologies that are are
invented and developed in our countries
from being used
for for military or intelligence
purposes by countries that do not share
our values
today we're also discussed our
unwavering support for the people of
Ukraine
and defend who are defending themselves
against most brutal aggression we've
seen a long time at the hands of Russia
and Putin the UK and the United States
together with more than 50 partners
have committed historic levels of
security assistance to Ukraine I want to
thank the Prime Minister for a strong
strong leadership contributing
significant amounts of security
assistance and training Ukrainian troops
so they can effectively use the
equipment and ammunition we've
collectively provided
and I'm bringing the world together
later this month to drive support from
Ukraine's long-term economic recovery
you're doing a great deal
so Mr Prime Minister thank you for
making the journey to Washington earlier
this week we marked the 79th anniversary
of D-Day and a timely reminder of a
proud history of our nation's share and
the values the values that we have long
stood together to defend
that's the unshakable foundation of this
special relationship and it is a special
relationship there's no country closer
to us than Great Britain today as NATO
allies Partners in Innovation as friends
in the shared vision of the future
and the two Nations our two Nations
ready to meet the challenges of our time
and meet them together
and I'm confident the United Kingdom of
the United States will continue to lead
the world toward greater peace
prosperity and security for all so thank
you again Mr Prime Minister and the
floor is yours
thank you Mr President before I begin my
remarks a word if I may on what happened
in France this morning
all our thoughts are with those affected
by this unfathomable attack including a
British child and with their families
I've been in touch with President macron
we stand ready to offer any assistance
that we can
Mr President Joe it is an honor to be
here at the White House and thank you
for your very warm welcome
not for decades has the relationship
between our two Nations been so
important the values we share our belief
in Freedom democracy and the rule of law
have never changed they never will
but what has changed are the challenges
that we face
and standing here together as our
predecessors have done for Generations
I feel confident that through the
strength of our relationship
we can shape the world once again in our
pursuit of Liberty prosperity and the
possibilities of a new age
and that begins with our highest
priority National Security
last time I was here in the U.S we
signed orcas the most significant
defense partnership in Generations
because we recognize that the security
of the Atlantic and Pacific regions
are indivisible and just a fortnight ago
in Hiroshima President Biden and I stood
with president zielinski and our G7
allies in a powerful display of unity
the UK is proud of our contribution
including providing tanks long-range
weapons and training Ukrainian soldiers
but let no one doubt
U.S leadership and resources are the
decisive contribution allowing the
forces of democracy and freedom to
prevail
as I said in Congress
and I say again now to President Biden
and to the American people
thank you
and just as we collaborate to protect
our national security
so must we increasingly do the same to
protect our Economic Security on which
our prosperity depends
countries like China and Russia are
willing to manipulate and exploit our
openness steal our intellectual property
use technology for authoritarian ends or
withdraw crucial resources like energy
they will not succeed today we have
agreed the Atlantic declaration
a new economic partnership for a new age
of a kind that has never been agreed
before
yes a partnership that protects our
citizens
but more than that
a test case for the kind of reimagined
alliances President Biden has spoken so
eloquently about
that means new investment this week
alone 14 billion pounds of new American
Investment has been committed into the
UK creating thousands of jobs
it means stronger Supply chains with a
new action plan on clean energy
and it means reducing trade barriers in
the Technologies of the future
with a new secure UK US data Bridge
helping tens of thousands of small
businesses
an agreement to work towards Mutual
recognition of more professional
qualifications in areas like engineering
and we're launching negotiations on a
new critical minerals agreement
once concluded this will give UK
companies stronger access to the U.S
market
and we're building on our extraordinary
shared strengths in cutting-edge future
Technologies with joint research
collaborations in areas like quantums
semiconductors and AI
now our job as Leaders is to ensure that
this technological Revolution makes us
more secure and not less
last week the pioneers of artificial
intelligence warned us about the scale
of the challenge as well as the
opportunity
the US and the UK are the world's
foremost Democratic AI powers
so today president and I agreed to work
together on AI safety including
multilaterally
now the UK looks forward to hosting the
first Global Summit on AI safety later
this year so that we can seize the
extraordinary possibilities of this new
technological age and do so with
confidence
and we are well placed to do so
I know some people have wondered what
kind of partner Britain would be after
we left the EU
I'd say judge us by our actions
we're committed to our values as ever
as reliable an ally as ever as
attractive an investment destination as
ever
but we're changing too
we're strengthening our relationships
not just with old friends like America
and in Europe but with new friends in
the indo-pacific too
and we now have the freedom to regulate
the new technologies that will shape our
economic future like AI more quickly and
flexibly that is the future that we are
creating in Britain confident proud and
free
and let me close with a personal
reflection
as Joe mentioned he and I have seen
quite a lot of each other in recent
months I gather our wives have even
started to take spin classes together
and we were talking earlier about our
hometowns Joe is very rightly proud of
Scranton and I was telling him a little
bit about Southampton in England where
I'm from now not everyone knows this but
it was in a church in Southampton where
in the days before he set sail for these
Shores that John Winthrop first spoke
about his dream of building a city on a
hill
and that reminds us that the
relationship between our two Nations is
unlike any other
our alliance is so strong because it is
not abstract it is rooted in our people
and it's never been about our history
alone
but about our ability to grasp the
future
we share the same beliefs pursue the
same purpose and act according to the
same ideals
and that's why today
as we meet the challenges of our time we
can depend on each other with absolute
conviction
when the United States and the United
Kingdom Stand Together the world is a
safer better and more prosperous place
and that's why ours is the indispensable
Alliance thank you
thank you Mr Prime Minister
all right first question goes to James
of the financial times
unless he left
thank you Mr President I appreciate the
question
um with um you spoke about your
unwavering support for the people of
Ukraine so much of that depends on
funding from the U.S Congress and now
with the counter-offensive underway when
do you expect to return to Congress and
ask for new funding and how much do you
expect you will need
and do you think that speaker McCarthy
will agree to it giving some skeptical
comments that we heard
um
and and to uh prime minister sunac
um you spoke earlier this week about the
importance
um of finding long-term security
arrangements and agreements for the
defense of Ukraine for many years ahead
um do you think that
um have you found a common position with
President Biden on that issue what's
your preferred model for a long-term
security agreement with respect to
Ukraine and does it need to be sorted
out before the Vilnius Summit thank you
let me Begin by answering your question
first of all the uh
ukrainians should speak to the military
operations and I won't do that from here
we've done everything we could
collectively but individually in the
United States to make them ready to
support
that that will they'll get us going to
continue
and an evolving situation that we're
we're very optimistic
in talks with the ukrainians and
ukrainians and particularly with
zelinski and our allies and partners
on commitments to Ukraine long-term
security
long-term security to deter future
aggression after this war ends is is the
goal and we're advancing this goal by
providing them the support Ukraine needs
now on the battlefield and helping them
strengthen their military over the long
term
the fact of the matter is that I believe
we'll have the funding necessary to
support Ukraine as long as it takes and
I believe that we're going to that that
support will be real even though there
are you hear some voices today on
Capitol Hill about whether or not we
should continue to support Ukraine and
for how long we should support them fact
of the matter is I ask people a picture
what would happen if we were not
supporting Ukraine do we think Russia
would stop and keep
do you think that's all there would be
happening I think not I think the vast
majority of my colleagues even the
critics think that would not be the case
as well
there's much more to say about Ukraine
but I hope that answers your direct
question
James thank you for the question if I if
I might actually touch on your first
question first and and so it's an
actually entirely reasonable or in the
American people to hear what I say and
hopefully acknowledge the thanks that we
have for their support of the situation
in Ukraine but also ask if everyone is
doing their bit and that's why as I said
the UK is proud to be behind the us the
biggest contributor to the military
effort in Ukraine and I think it's right
that other countries also step up and do
their part we're lucky to have America's
investment in European security but we
need to share the burden alongside you
which is why defense spending in the UK
has has been above the two percent NATO
Benchmark it's on an increasing
trajectory and we would encourage other
countries to follow the lead that the US
and and the UK set because our security
is collective I think the other thing
for you to know about us as an ally is
we also view security as indivisible
between the Euro Atlantic region in the
Pacific
that's why the orca's partnership is so
important that's why we're strengthening
our engagement and alliances in that
region too so that the US can count on
the UK as a partner and an ally sharing
the burden but also working together in
every sphere that it matters and on your
latter question I agree with what the
president said it's about deterrence
President Putin will be thinking that he
can wait us out
that the alliance will Tire will get
fatigued and will give up now that is
not the case and the more we can put in
place support for Ukraine not just in
the here and now but support that will
last for a time and for years to come I
think it sends a strong signal to him
that there is no point trying to wait us
out we're not going anywhere we will be
here for as long as it takes and
hopefully that will speed up the
calculation in his mind that he should
withdraw his forces and stop what is an
illegal and unprovoked act of aggression
also if you don't mind my making an
addendum I point out that uh
not only do we have the Europe
responding
I spent a lot of time in Japan
the Japanese have stepped up
they've stepped up in terms of their
budget they've stepped up in terms of
their involvement they stepped and
stepped up in terms of the support for
Ukraine realizing that an event a a a
glaring Invasion with no free text of
anything other than conquering land
occurring in the 21st century is a
danger not only in Europe but everywhere
in the world
the next question from uh from the PBS
news hour Laura
thank you Mr President I think you're
going to steal the mic that's why yeah
Laura Brown Lopez with the PBS NewsHour
the country Mr
states are passing law
uh passing anti-lgbtq
anti-transgender laws that restrict
rights in medical care intimidation is
on the rise this week anti-lgbtq
protesters turned violent in California
and also recently I spoke to the parents
of a transgender girl in Texas who told
me that they're afraid and that they're
considering leaving not just their state
but the country sir why do you think
this is happening and what do you say to
parents like the ones that I spoke to to
those families who are contemplating
leaving the country because they don't
feel safe anymore
prime minister sunac thank you you
mentioned that AI has been a key part of
your visit what are the U.S and the UK
what is the UK doing with the US to
protect elections and democracy from AI
generated disinformation campaigns waged
at scale by Foreign actors and you also
mentioned the warning letter sent by AI
leaders about the Potential Threat that
this technology if misused can pose to
humanity
how is regulating artificial
intelligence going to be any different
than what has been done at the global
scale so far to deal with climate change
another existential threat
let me answer your first question
first of all maybe quietly when we
finish this you can give me the number
of that family
and I will call them let them know that
the president and this Administration
has their back and I mean that look
as president I was proud to end the band
on transgender troops in our military
sign the respect for Marriage Act
strengthen the Civil Rights protection
so I'll be Chief lbgt Americans and
advanced LGBT human rights around the
globe
but our fight is far far from over
because we have some hysterical and I
would argue Prejudice people who are
engaged in all what you see going on
around the country
it's a it's an appeal to fear and it's
appeal that is totally thoroughly
unjustified and ugly
it's wrong
for that a person can be married in the
morning in the United States and fired
in the afternoon by their employer
because they are they're gay
it's wrong that the violence and hate
crimes targeting lgbtq people is rising
it's wrong that extreme officials are
pushing hateful bills targeting
transgender children terrifying families
and criminalizing doctors
these are our kids these are our
neighbors it's cruel and it's callous
not somebody else's kids they're all our
kids
they're the kids that are and our
children are the kite strings that hold
our national Ambitions Aloft it matters
a great deal how we treat everyone in
this country
and the fact is that I'm announcing
today a series of new initiatives
that we're taking to protect the LGBT
community was going to do this at the
four out of the South lawn we're having
Pride day but we're going to have to
postpone it because of the the climate
because of the weather and the pollution
out there because of the fires but uh
number one we're going to strengthen the
physical safety dedicated resources the
federal coordination of better protect
Pride celebrations marches community
centers Health Care Providers and small
businesses and secondly we're addressing
civil rights violations a new
coordinator to protect LGBT students
from book bands which make it harder for
kids to learn and may violate their
civil rights at the same time
we're also engaging in mental health and
and other supports more Mental Health
Resources and funding to help families
support their kids new efforts to
protect lgbtq kids in foster care and
steps to end the absolute
end of lgbtq homelessness
Congress has to pass and I'm not giving
up on this just like you told me we
couldn't get the Marriage Act passed
Congress must pass must pass the
equality act and send it to my desk
lgbtq Americans especially children
you're loved you're heard and this
Administration has your back and I
needed we are not relenting one single
second to make sure that they're
protected
Laura the on on your question it's clear
that AI can bring incredible and will
bring incredible benefits to society our
economies to all of us and actually one
of your leading Venture capitalists just
published a an essay on this which made
the point very eloquently yesterday and
it's also clear though that it does pose
very real risks that we as Leaders need
to be cognizant of and put in place the
guard rails to mitigate against should
president and Biden and I had a very
good conversation on this just a couple
of weeks ago in Japan in one of our
sessions in Hiroshima and we are aligned
in wanting to discuss with other
countries what those guard rails should
be here in the US you've convened all
the companies together recently we've
done the same in Downing Street just a
couple of weeks ago and I think there
are a series of measures that we can
Implement working cooperatively as we
have been discussing that will ensure
that we can enjoy the benefits of this
technology whilst mitigating against
their risks and that's what our citizens
would expect and you talk about climate
change you know we come together at cop
to work multilaterally across multiple
countries to bring down carbon emissions
to get funding to the countries that
need it to share research on how we can
develop the green technologies of the
future indeed that's part of our
conversations and agreement today that
we need to bring that same Spirit of
urgency I think to the challenges and
opportunities that AI poses because the
pace of the technological change is
faster than people have anticipated and
I think the letter that you mentioned
kind of reminded us that we do need to
work urgently to address this issue and
I'm delighted that Joe and I and others
will be doing that with all great haste
and I think a couple of questions on our
end could I call on the BBC
thank you Chris Mason from BBC News
prime minister your aim as a
conservative party at the last general
election was a full free trade deal with
America isn't the simple truth of what's
been announced today an acknowledgment
of a failure to do that and to the
president why won't you do a full trade
agreement with the UK
thank you
so if you if you look at what we've
announced today what it does is respond
to the particular opportunities and
challenges that we face right now and
into the future and it asks the question
what do we need to do working together
that can bring most benefit to our
citizens as quickly as possible and our
agreement does that it's a first of a
Kind agreement that's ambitious in what
it seeks to achieve I think that I've
structured around a couple of different
areas the first is economic security
because the challenges we Face are much
more economic in nature
big subject of our discussions at the G7
recently and the only way we're going to
meet those challenges is to work
together to strengthen the resilience of
our supply chains to research the
Technologies of the future together and
that's what we've announced today is a
partnership that will deepen our
cooperation to strengthen the economic
security and that's good for all our
citizens at home and those risks have
intensified in the past couple of years
I think that's very evident but it also
seeks to build prosperity and create
jobs in both of our countries we've
announced billions of pounds of
investment into the UK which is going to
support thousands of jobs and the
agreement that we've struck today will
continue to do that it will support tens
of thousands of small businesses in the
UK removing unnecessary red tape so that
they can trade and do business in the
U.S far easier and I think those types
of specific targeted measures that will
deliver real benefits to people as
quickly as possible are the right things
for us to be focused on but I think
being no doubt as
Joe and I were discussing earlier the
economic relationship between our two
countries has never been stronger
uh the the trade is worth hundreds of
billions of pounds of dollars a year
over a million of our citizens in each
other's countries work in each other's
companies we're one of the largest
investors in each other's countries and
that trade is growing at something like
20 last year so the relationship is
strong it's booming but our agreement
today focuses on the particular
challenges opportunities of the moment
we're in and I think that's the right
thing for us both to be focused on
I think we had a really good discussion
today
about our economic relationship and uh
we've launched negotiations on critical
materials
and an agreement to deal with climate
crisis for example there is no reason
why
Great Britain will not play a major role
in not only critical materials but in
investing in
the United States American all of our
initiatives relating the need for
critical materials including Battery
Technology and a whole range of things
number one number two uh cooperating on
data and AI
it is a
limitless capacity impossibility
we but we have to do it with great care
not relative to one another but relative
to the issue because when I convened the
leaders in AI about I think we're 13
here in the United States
the very architects of this AI are
they're also very concerned about it
getting out of hand
and we've got to make sure we're all on
the same page
and we're looking to Great Britain to
lead that effort this fall and putting
together a proposal a group of Nations
to deal with how do we deal with this it
not only has the potential to uh to cure
cancer
and many other things that are just
beyond our comprehension but has the
potential to do great damage if it's not
controlled and so we're looking for
I'll overstate it we're looking for
watermarks on everything that has to do
it's produced by AI so we know from
whence it comes but there's a lot we
have to do we're also addressing the
National Security risk posed by certain
types of outbound Investments
I
had a discussion with
with Xi Jinping in China why was I not
transferring certain technological
capabilities and I said very simply
because you're using them for weapons of
mass destruction and intelligence
intervention and I said we can work out
something on that we'd have a very
different relationship
so what we're trying to do is figure out
how together
we can make sure that we have the let me
back up and say it this way
I don't think ever in the history of
human endeavor
has there been as fundamental potential
technological change as is presented by
artificial intelligence
it is staggering it is staggering you
have some of these leaders in the
industry talking about how they're
concerned whether machine will be able
to begin to think for itself
not need to be programmed I mean it's
just I know it sounds like science
fiction
but it is close to science fiction some
of the things it has enormous potential
and we're looking to uh Great Britain to
help lead that effort to figure out a
way through this so we're in full total
cooperation
because there's no one no country we
have greater faith in being able to
negotiate this not negotiate with
individuals negotiate our way through
this then then the Prime Minister and so
uh we uh we're in lockstep
last question thank you last question is
the times
thank you Chris Knight from the times
prime minister you've made clear your
support for free trade but is today's
agreement essentially a recognition that
in light of uh covid the growing threat
of China Russia's invasion of Ukraine
that the era of unfettered globalization
is over and if so the US has made clear
that it thinks that requires a much more
interventionist industrial policy to
respond to that why do you think that
approach is wrong for the UK
um and Mr President what do you say to
those abroad who say that you all new
Washington consensus is simply a fancier
way of saying America First and in light
of the warm words just now about UK US
defense collaboration particularly in
Ukraine do you think it's time for the
first British NATO Secretary General in
two decades
sorry is it time for a British NATO
Secretary General
maybe that remains to be seen we're
going to have to get a consensus within
NATO to see that happen they have a
candidate who's a very qualified
individual but we're going to have uh we
have a lot of discussion between us but
in NATO to determine what the outcome of
that will be and with regard to
the first part of your question you
wanted me to respond to
it was about is the new Washington
consensus that you and your National
Security advisors set out Simply another
way of saying America first which some
overseas think it is well look my
economic policy is totally consistent
with what I think
is in the interest of our NATO allies
and our allies around the world
one of the things that I decided to do
and I find that uh The Wall Street
Journal and I'm sure there's someone
here from The Wall Street Journal
another
Publications they're talking about
biodynamics I didn't realize it was a I
had biodynamics going but the bottom
line was this
that the fundamental change is taking
place in terms of international trade
nobody in at least very few people in
the United States and I suspect around
the world knew what a supply chain meant
what were they were talking about with
supply chain
when we found out during the pandemic
that the reason why we couldn't build
automobiles was because the outfit that
we got our semiconductors from in
Southeast Asia had shut down because of
pandemic we realized that I decided that
no longer would we rely on one Center of
support for any of the things that are
needed for our economic growth and I
made it clear into all our NATO allies
and our partners as well that although
we were going to generate a for example
an AI capacity here excuse me a uh
semiconductor capacity here in the
United States
attracting literally uh several hundred
billion dollars in investment that that
was available to all of our all of our
allies all of our friends and they're
investing as the as we are and
benefiting in a similar way
the bottom line here for me is that I
think that the world is changing in a
way that
globalization is still real but the
measure of what we used to call in the
United States trickle-down economics
where if the if the
trickle-down economics resulted in and
both and democratican Republic
administrations for Generations in
making sure we found the cheapest labor
in the world sent the product to send
the work to those to that neighbor or
those neighbors who have the cheapest
labor and they send back their products
I'm not doing that anymore
we're going to make sure that we in fact
have a flip of that we're sending
capacity
here in the United States we're
attracting capacity to build here in the
United States to send product overseas
not not the reverse
and I know it sounds simplistic but it's
working
so far and it's not going to hurt any of
our allies or friends in terms of the
trade pieces matter of fact I'm finding
they're benefiting from it as well
because they're engaging in it with us
and at home they're doing similar things
so that's why we talked about the need
to have relationships in terms of
certain materials the battery
technologies to share we rely on Great
Britain to produce a lot of that for us
so it is increasing trade but right now
it looks like it is because the United
States is doing so incredibly well it
makes it look like it's only the United
States it's not it's a change in
Direction in terms of how we view
generating economic growth
and just to add to that I'd say I'm
absolutely of the view that the United
States this President does not believe
in zero-sum competition amongst allies
that's what we declared together with
our G7 Partners just a few weeks ago in
Hiroshima this is a president and an
Administration that is completely
attuned to the needs and concerns of its
allies on these issues and you can see
that today as the president said we are
launching negotiations between the UK
and the US on a critical minerals
agreement so that the U.S can provide us
with that interaction cooperation we
need and the Atlantic declaration that
we've announced today just talks about
strengthening deepening our cooperation
it's not about looking in and being
protection it's about the exact opposite
of that and it's about strengthening
that cooperation across the full
spectrum
of economic technological and other
spheres and and that's what you will see
you'll see that from the president
you'll see it from me you'll see the UK
and the us working even more closely
together on all the big economic issues
of our time because that's what the
moment demands and that's what our
Citizens need us to do and that's what
the president and I plan to deliver
with our citizens look
the global South they're going to be a
billion people in Africa very shortly
one billion
at the G7 it was originally called build
back better world but we're talking
about there's a new PPI anyway an
industrial policy that we're all signed
on to to provide the countries in Africa
and in the in the global South an
opportunity to grow significantly grow
which benefits the United States
benefits your benefits every country
because the reverse is true if we don't
figure a way in which these countries
can grow and participate and have to
then be able to build infrastructure
you know the Canadian the excuse me the
Chinese have a part have a belt Road
initiative well the old road initiative
turns out to be a debt and uh
confiscation program not going very far
but what we're doing and we're going to
be doing with our NATO allies with the
G7 is providing opportunities for
example Angola a group should be in a
position very soon to have the largest
Glo uh the largest solar facility in the
world generating significant amounts of
energy benefits us benefits them brings
them into the 21st century in a way that
they've never been before we're talking
about building and I have my team
putting together with other countries as
well
to build a railroad from the Pacific
Ocean from the Atlantic Ocean all the
way to the Indian Ocean never occurred
before how we're our Departments of
Agriculture are working with these
countries so there's a significant
amount of cooperation not to hoard
capacity but to expand capacity to
further expand opportunity because we
all benefit from it and one thing I've
learned is that we are not going to be
able to deal with the global warming
which is a
consequential single most consequential
threat to humanity if we don't do it
unless we engage more together not fewer
not not less together
and so the United States will do what it
can do well and invite all of our
partners to be part of it if we can
thank you
ladies and gentlemen distinguished
guests please remain in your seats as
the principals and official delegations
depart the East room
I'm supposed to walk off the stage
Russian Republicans where's the money
I'm joking Mr President can I try to
promote a bunch of malarkey Mr President
what do you say to Americans to convince
them that they should trust the
independence and fairness of the justice
department when your predecessor Donald
Trump repeatedly attacks it because you
notice I have never once not one single
time
suggested the justice department what
they should do or not do well to bring
into charge and not bring a charge
I'm honest
[Music]